jetzt aber der erste Redner zu diesem
debattenpunkt am Pult Stefan Rolo
ruhenhof aus der Unionsfraktion
bereits corona-pandemie hat der
deutschen Wirtschaft einen Vorgeschmack
darauf gegeben was es heißt wenn
wichtige Rohstoffe knapp werden die
Folge massive Preissteigerung eine
gedrosselte Produktion und
Produktionsstopps mit staatlichen
Stützungsmaßnahmen hat die große
Koalition 2020 2021 eine Pleitewelle in
der deutschen Wirtschaft verhindert die
corona-krise hat gezeigt der
Produktionsstandort Deutschland ist ohne
eine verlässliche
Rohstoffversorgung massiv gefährdet und
der russische Angriffskrieg macht
deutlich Deutschland ist nicht nur bei
Energierohstoffen sondern auch bei
vielen mineralischen Rohstoffen von
einzelnen Ländern viel zu abhängig
geworden Rohstoffe die im Zweifelsfall
auch als geostrategische Waffe
eingesetzt werden gegen Deutschland
gegen Europa liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran
arbeiten unsere sauerstoffabhängigkeit
zu reduzieren damit sich in unserer
Volkswirtschaft auch damit sich unsere
Volkswirtschaft auch in stürmischen
Zeiten international behaupten kann um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen brauchen wir
einen Bündel von Maßnahmen eine
Fokussierung liebe Freunde und Freunde
von den Grünen allein auf die
Kreislaufwirtschaft reicht hier bei
weitem nicht aus denn bei zwei Drittel
der von der EU-Kommission als kritisch
eingestuften Rohstoffe liegt die
Recycling gerade bei unter einem Prozent
unter einem Prozent das unterstreicht
wir müssen beim Recycling deutlich
besser werden aber wir müssen uns auch
beim
Rohstoffabbau im In- und Ausland viel
stärker engagieren
denn nur dann werden wir in Deutschland
eine hohe Wertschöpfung und
vielversprechender Arbeitsplätze sichern
können denn gerade in
Zukunftstechnologien sind kritische
Rohstoffe zwingend erforderlich ohne
skandium keine Elektrolyse ohne Platin
kein Rechenzentrum ohne Seltene Erden
keine E-Autos über 90 Prozent der in der
EU verarbeiteten Seltenen Erden kommen
heute aus China liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Zahlen zeigen sehr deutlich
es besteht dringender Handlungsbedarf
Deutschland und Europa sollten weder bei
der digitalen Transformation noch bei
der klimatransformation vom Wohlwollen
Chinas Russlands oder anderer Länder
abhängig sein
vor diesen Hintergrund müsste die
Bundesregierung jetzt eigentlich alles
daran setzen die rohstoff-bezugsländer
zu diversifizieren deutsche Unternehmen
in Drittländern bei Explorationen
Genehmigung Abbau und Verarbeitung
politisch und finanziell deutlich
wirksamer zu unterstützen etwa durch
eine verstärkte Nutzung bestehender
rohstoffpartnerschaften oder durch neuer
Partnerschaften und Handelsabkommen
stattdessen bringt das Grün geführte
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium das bereits
ausverhandelte eu-freiheitsabkommen mit
dem Rohstoff leihreichen Land Chile in
Gefahr warum weil die Grünen das
nachhaltigkeitskapitel nachverhandeln
wollten um ihre Parteibasis zu
besänftigen liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde von den Grünen hören Sie endlich
mit ihrem parteipolitischen Spielchen
auf dies schadet der Europäischen Union
und Deutschland massiv machen sie
endlich das was der Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland jetzt dringend braucht und
was auch sie für ihre Energiewende
benötigen setzen mit Hilfe von
rohstoffpartnerschaften und
Handelsabkommen alles daran unsere
rohstoffbezugsquellen zu diversifizieren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Blick sollte sich auch auf die heimische
Rohstoffgewinnung richten Deutschland
verfügt über einige energetische und
mineralische Rohstoffvorkommen die
bisher jedoch nicht genutzt werden Liebe
ampelfraktion ihr Koalitionsvertrag
zielt auf eine Erleichterung des
heimischen Rohstoffs ab das ist
angesichts der angespannten
geopolitischen Lage umso wichtiger es
ist richtig aber nach fast einem Jahr
ampelregierung drängt sich die Frage auf
wie ernsthaft verfolgen sie eigentlich
dieses Ziel
denn zu der geplanten zu der geplanten
Novellierung des Bergrechts gab es im
Mai ein Fachgespräch das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium lud
insgesamt 30 Experten ein
Rechtsanwälte Vertreter des ökoinstituts
Landes- und Bundesbeamte darunter war
jedoch nur ein einziger Vertreter der
rohstoffgewinnenden Industrie eine echte
Einbindung der Industrie hat bis heute
nicht stattgefunden und bei der
laufenden Novellierung des
raumordnungsgesetzes muss man die
Erleichterung für den
Rohstoffabbau mit der Lupe suchen das
ist kein Fortschritt das ist Stillstand
also ziehen sie endlich die Praktiker
heran damit die geplante Novellierung
des einschlägigen Gesetzes der
einschlägigen Gesetze einen
tatsächlichen Beitrag zur
Rohstoffsicherung leistet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Ereignisse der letzten Jahre haben
gezeigt eine verlässliche
Rohstoffversorgung ist für unsere
Volkswirtschaft existenziell deutschland
braucht ein Gesamtkonzept zur
Rohstoffsicherung das neben dem bereits
genannten Punkten auch die strategische
Bevorratung von kritischen Rohstoffen
etwa mit Hilfe einer Rohstoff
bevorratungsrücklage umfasst und
Maßnahmen zur effizienteren Ressourcen
Nutzung vorsieht wir als Union haben in
unserem antragsdiziert aus welchen
Bestandteilen ein gesamtgrund
Gesamtkonzept bestehen sollte liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von den
Regierungsfraktionen das ist die von
ihnen so oft geforderte konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit sie haben die Chance
unserem Antrag heute zu folgen und die
Weichen richtig zu stellen wir sind
gespannt wie konstruktiv sie sind vielen
Dank
Stefan ruhedorf aus der Unionsfraktion
hat den Antrag seiner Fraktion hier
vorgestellt es geht um die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit Deutschland es geht
um die Rohstoffsicherung die deutsche
Industrie macht sich da auch sehr große
Sorgen insbesondere was die sogenannten
Seltenen Erden angeht jetzt Sebastian
Rohloff für die SPD-Fraktion zu sagen
auch wenn es die Aufmerksamkeit des
Hauses wahrscheinlich nicht erhöht ich
glaube die meisten von ihnen kennen das
Brettspiel die Siedler von Catan und das
mag einen ganz vereinfachen der
Vergleich sein aber es bringt schon auf
den Punkt wie die deutsche Wirtschaft
funktioniert wenn man nicht die nötigen
Rohstoffe hat um sich durch
Verhandlungsgeschick die Rohstoffe die
man fehlt nicht organisiert dann hat man
keine Chance zu gewinnen und genau das
gilt auch für die deutsche Wirtschaft
die Ampel hat den Wert von Rohstoffen
erkannt und ich freue mich dass die
Union dieses Thema hier drei Wochen
nachdem wir den deutsch-französischen
Aufschlag zum EU-Gesetz über kritische
Rohstoffe
diskutieren hier auf die Tagesordnung
setzt der Antrag verspricht einiges und
wie ich sie an der Stelle gelegentlich
sage die Analyse ist auch oft richtig
und einige Forderungen ich werde darauf
eingehen finden meine Unterstützung
spannend wird wenn man ins Detail geht
und ganz oft reden wir auch nicht über
viel Neues mal sehen wir gucken mal zum
Beispiel fordern Sie die Unterstützung
von unternehmerischen
rohstoffaktivitäten im Ausland am
Beispiel der japanischen Agentur yorkmek
ja richtig steht aber auch schon im
deutsch-französischen Aufschlag haben
wir vor drei Wochen schon aufs Gleis
gesetzt sie fordern neue
rohstoffpartnerschaften und die
Diversifizierung wir haben es gerade
wieder gehört auch das ist richtig Frau
Dr Brandner war in Südamerika der
Bundeskanzler und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister in Kanada
dementsprechend sind wir auch da schon
dran die Einbindung des Themas Rohstoffe
in den nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
hat Anna-Lena baerbock schon
thematisiert und ist auf dem Weg und die
Praktikerinnen und Praktiker die bei der
Novellierung des Bergrechts eine Rolle
spielen sind auch schon
dementsprechend sind wir da auch Linie
aber wir haben es schon aufs Gleis
gesetzt während sie heute darüber reden
wollen es ist korrekt dass wir eine
größere Diversifizierung brauchen
insbesondere was die Abhängigkeit von
China betrifft wir wissen auch dass
China mit Blick auf seltener Erden
wahrscheinlich ein wichtiger
Handelspartner sein kann aber wir haben
spätestens am Beispiel von Russland
gesehen warum das kein sinnvollen
Entwicklung ist und dementsprechend
müssen wir da Vorsicht walten lassen und
andere Alternativen
klar ist auch und das ist der nächste
Stichpunkt der in diesem Zusammenhang
immer kommt dass das lieferkettengesetz
gerade vor diesem Hintergrund dringender
erforderlich ist denn je klar ist auch
dass das für die Unternehmen keine
zusätzliche Belastung sein darf und dass
das gut umsetzbar ausgestaltet werden
muss wir brauchen es aber gerade mit
Blick auf die menschenrechtssituationen
in schwierigen Ländern mit denen wir
jetzt teilweise noch Handel treiben um
so dringender und deswegen dürfen wir
keinesfalls aufs lieferkettengesetz
verzichten oder es verzögern
ernüchternd ist leider dass sie sich in
dem Antrag wieder vor allem auf große
abbauvorhaben
fokussieren ich weiß nicht warum sie
kleinere Bergbauvorhaben immer so ein
bisschen ignorieren weil ich glaube dass
das auch eine Möglichkeit sein kann die
Vielzahl der Projekte und das Angebot
auf dem Markt zu erhöhen glaube dass die
ein bisschen ein Schatten da sein führen
und das finde ich ein bisschen schade im
Übrigen hat das Kabinett ja am Mittwoch
den 15 Bericht der Aktivitäten des Fonds
für Rohstoffe und der einzelnen
rohstoffabkommen zur Kenntnis genommen
und beschlossen und da können wir sehen
dass wenn starken entwicklungseffekt in
diesem Bereich haben leider
konzentrieren wir uns da im Moment noch
ein bisschen zu sehr auf agrarrostoffe
und Institutionen ich glaube darüber
nachdenken dass zu verändern und auch da
zu dieser replizieren
ich glaube wir brauchen mutige Schritte
ich kann mir zum Beispiel gut vorstellen
dass wir mittelfristig so eine Art
Rohstoff Google Maps brauchen das klingt
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen naiv aber
als Grundlage kann es Geologie
datengesetz dienen die Daten die man da
hat kann man auf breiter aufstellen kann
man ergänzen und kann dann entsprechend
gucken welche potenziellen
Rohstoffvorkommen man hat und das zum
Beispiel bei der Planung oder dem Abbau
nutzen und da müssen die Länder prüfen
inwieweit man auf die Daten zugreifen
kann und inwieweit wir da auch zum
Beispiel noch einen Explorationsprogramm
des Bundes dazu schalten können und ich
glaube diese innovativen Ideen braucht
es wir haben in diesem Bereich eine
hervorragende Forschungslandschaft wir
müssen aufpassen dass die durch die
fehlende Nachbesetzung von Lehrstühlen
zum Beispiel nicht ausgedünnt wird und
wir müssen
Alternativen zu den
importierten Rohstoffen finden wo immer
es möglich ist mein Kollege Tews wird
auf die Kreislaufwirtschaft eingehen
weil selbstverständlich klar ist dass
man rohstoffstrategien nicht ohne
Kreislaufwirtschaft denken kann es war
völlig klar jedes Produkt was zumindest
teilweise recycelbar ist muss nicht neu
hergestellt werden und dafür braucht es
keine Rohstoffe und das ist ein ebenso
wichtiger Punkt wie das Förderprogramm
nachwachsende Rohstoffe aus dem
Landwirtschaftsministerium da werden
innovative biobasierte Produkte
besonders gefördert zum Beispiel
bioverbundwerkstoffe aus naturfördern
brauchen wir für den Karosseriebau
Porsche macht das schon in kleinen Serie
und das ist genau der richtige Weg den
wir weitergehen müssen
darüber hinaus kann ich mir vorstellen
dass wir eine Agentur für
sprunginnovation schaffen und da zum
Beispiel also die gibt es aber die
ausweiten und wir da eine Challenge
Unabhängigkeit von kritischen Rohstoffen
zum Beispiel schaffen das hätte glaube
ich auch was Fortschritte was im
Kreativwettbewerb betrifft etc guten
Effekt und anhand des von der EU
definierten Begriffs kritischen
Rohstoffe können alle Interessierten vom
Forschungsunternehmen bis zum kleinen
garagenbastler wenn man so möchte Ideen
da einreichen und wir wissen auch dass
gute Ideen auch schon spontan entstanden
sind und auch irgendwo herkommen wo man
sich vielleicht nicht unmittelbar
erwartet neue Fördermethoden um aus
alten Abraum halten noch kritische
Rohstoffe zu gewinnen Wind aus meiner
Sicht ebenso förderwürdig wie neue
Produkte die bisher kritische Rohstoffe
gebraucht haben aber anders konstruiert
werden und eben ohne kritische Rohstoffe
klarkommen neu entwickelte Materialien
die dieselben Eigenschaften dann aber
haben werden genauso förderwürdig aus
meiner und ich habe ja gesagt das ist
auch durchaus Übereinstimmungen gibt ich
unterstütze zum Beispiel ihre Forderung
die Verordnung zur Natur auf Zeit
möglichst schnell umzusetzen ich glaube
dass das gerade auch für
Planungsverfahren sind voll sein kann
und ja wir haben alle den großen Auftrag
die Steigerung der Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung wenn es um die Förderung von
Rohstoffen geht egal ob das die
Kiesgrube vor Ort ist oder was anderes
zu steigern zum Abschluss
und das finde ich dann auch wieder
schade machen sie ja wie gesagt gute
Vorschläge sagen aber das geht alles nur
im Rahmen der verfügbaren
Haushaltsmittel also riesenvorbehalt und
wir wissen alle dass die Bäume im
Haushalt gerade alles andere als in den
Himmel wachsen dementsprechend entwertet
dass ihren Antrag ein bisschen das finde
ich sehr schade ich freue mich aber auf
die weitere Diskussion mit ihnen weil
vielleicht kriegen wir auch zusammen was
sind in der Koalition auf jeden Fall
aber vielleicht gibt es auch
konstruktive Momente der cdu/csu wir
freuen uns drauf vielen Dank
Sebastian Rohloff aus der SPD-Fraktion
ein paar Informationen rund um die
Rohstoffstrategie der Bundesregierung
die gibt es seit 2010 und sie ist dann
2020 fortgeschrieben worden im Moment
wird an einer weiteren Fortschreibung
gearbeitet und sich steuert maßgeblich
die deutsche
Rohstoffpolitik und dazu gleich mehr
jetzt mal die Kaufmann aus der
afd-fraktion
in der deutschen Wirtschaft brennt es
mittlerweile lichterloh drastische
energieverteuerung und ein zunehmender
Mangel an verschiedensten Rohstoffen und
Vorprodukten sind die größten Probleme
beide Probleme haben einige gemeinsame
wesentliche Ursache und zwar die
weltfremde ökosozialistische Ideologie
der Grünen
muss man einfach so sagen
akuter Rohstoffmangel und historischer
Einbruch deutscher Export ist die Folge
einer verfehlten
Außenwirtschaftspolitik es gibt beinahe
keinen Wirtschaftsbereich der vom
Rohstoffmangel nicht betroffen wäre Holz
Metalle Gummi Kunststoff sind in
Deutschland zu Mangelware geworden
Unternehmen in den Bereichen
baumaschinenbau Elektrotechnik
Medizin Chemie und viele andere klagen
über überdimensionale Preissteigerungen
und akute Lieferengpässe
die Folgen sind drastisch
Preiserhöhungen Inflation
auftragsverluste eine Pleitewelle die
sie noch im Ausschuss diese Woche
verleugnet haben und mehr noch durch das
unsägliche
lieferkettengesetz ein langjähriger
Wunsch der Grünen laufen deutsche
Unternehmer aller Branchen nun Gefahr
für irgendwelche Missstände bei ihren
ausländischen Lieferanten in Haftung
genommen zu werden weil die dortigen
Rahmenbedingungen möglicherweise nicht
ihren Standorts entsprechend Stichwort
feministische Außenpolitik das ist doch
doch ein Irrsinn meine Damen und Herren
so ein Unfug würde vielen anderen
Ländern wie beispielsweise China nicht
im Traum einfallen dort akzeptiert man
dort akzeptiert man den bewährten
Grundsatz hören sie gut zu dass jedes
Land seine gewachsene Kult ich habe
beispielsweise China gesagt man
akzeptiert dass jedes Land seine
gewachsene Kultur hat die man nicht
oberlehrerhaft von außen verändern darf
und deshalb verfolgen diese Länder eine
pragmatische Außenhandelspolitik die
sowohl vom dem eigenen Volk dient als
auch der wohlstandsmehrung in den
Lieferländern Deutschland dagegen frönt
einer Ideologie getriebenen grünen
Außenhandelspolitik die am Ende gar
niemandem dient weder uns selbst noch
den potenziellen Lieferländern
außerdem müssen wir weg von einer grünen
Energiepolitik die uns schadet denn
unser Land braucht günstige Energie
nicht teure sie wollen ja teure Energie
Kollegen von den Grünen wir brauchen
aber günstige Energie als Lebensader für
die deutsche Wirtschaft und wir brauchen
grundlastfähigen Strom deshalb
sehen sie endlich ein dass ein
Industrieland wie unseres ohne Kernkraft
nicht am Leben bleiben wird ihr fauler
Kompromiss drei AKWs 100 Tage länger zu
laufen zu lassen ist doch völlig
ungeeignete Energiekrise unseres Landes
auch nur im Ansatz zu bewältigen deshalb
lassen sie die noch laufenden drei
Kernkraftwerke dauerhaft am Netz holen
Sie auch diejenigen drei wieder zurück
die derzeit noch
reaktivierbar sind öffnen Sie Nord
Stream 2 dann wird der Strompreis sofort
sinken und Bürger und Unternehmen können
endlich aufatmen vielen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
komme ich noch mal zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 26c die Zeit für die
namentliche Abstimmung ist gleich vorbei
ist noch ein Mitglied im Haus das noch
nicht abgestimmt hat
gut dann
dann jetzt schnell dann machen wir noch
mal mit dem
dann reden wir noch ein wenig über
dieses wichtige Thema dann rufe ich auf
für die Bundesregierung als nächste
Rednerin die Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin dr Franziska Brandner
so und während einige jetzt ganz schnell
in die Lobby laufen um noch abzustimmen
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
beim Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
wir stehen bei dem bei der
Rohstoffversorgung vor erheblichen
Herausforderungen erstens
corona-pandemie russische Angriffskrieg
haben deutlich gemacht wie fragil manche
Rohstoff Lieferketten sind zweitens im
Bereich metallischer Rohstoffe bestehen
zentrale Abhängigkeiten vor allen Dingen
von China 3 seit langem wissen wir um
die strategische Bedeutung von
Rohstoffen für Zukunftstechnologien und
die grüne Transformation
leider Herr hohenhoff hat die
Vorgängerregierung hier zu lange
gezögert
und
deswegen gehen wir es jetzt aktiv an wir
machen eine aktive Rohstoffpolitik und
ich skizziere in drei Punkten was das
bedeutet erstens diversifizieren durch
europäische und internationale
Zusammenarbeit wir beleben die
rohstoffpartnerschaften die es bis jetzt
gibt die aber hauptsächlich bis jetzt
auf dem Papier existieren und wir
hinterlegen Sie jetzt mit konkreten
Projekten mit konkreten
unternehmerischen Aktivitäten und das
ist auch richtig und wichtig
sie haben zu Chile gesprochen
offensichtlich dem EU Chile Abkommen
offensichtlich wissen sie nicht dass die
chilenische Regierung das Abkommen noch
nachverhandeln möchte um genau im
Rohstoffbereich eine Erleichterung für
die
weitererarbeitung in ihrem Land zu
bekommen das ist das was der aktuelle
Stand ist und das ist auch etwas was wir
unterstützen es ist in unserem Interesse
das Weiterverarbeitung nicht nur in
China stattfindet sondern auch in
Ländern wie Chile das ist unser Ziel und
da gehen wir auf die chilenische
Regierung zu genau das sind die
Partnerschaften der Zukunft wie wir sie
uns vorstellen
und natürlich geht es uns auch darum
dass die Rohstoffe die wir die wir
fördern die wir unterstützen werden zu
fördern auch auf hohen ökologischen und
sozialen menschenrechtlichen Standards
abgebaut werden absolut wir wollen keine
Kinderarbeit in den Rohstoffen die wir
unterstützen wir wollen keine
Wasserverschwendung sondern die beste
deutsche Technologie um Wasser zu sparen
um grüne Energie damit zu verknüpfen das
ist der Vorteil den wir als Deutsche
haben wenn wir in diese Länder gehen
dass wir die besten Technologien haben
dass wir eben auch mit indigenen Völkern
zum Beispiel umgehen können unsere
Unternehmen und das ist das was uns
ausmacht und was wir nicht aufgeben
sollten was in ihrem Antrag aber fehlt
und deswegen appellieren wir nicht nur
ein Unternehmen zu diversifizieren
sondern wir unterstützen Sie gezielt
dabei das reicht von der klassischen
projektabsicherung über ufk-garantien
bis zu und das ist das was wir jetzt
planen Beteiligung an Rohstoffgewinnung
weiterverarbeitungs- und
recyclingprojekten zum Beispiel durch
einen gemeinsamen deutsch-französischen
wenn möglich sogar europäischen
Rohstofffonds und das ist auch das Gebot
der Stunde dass wir hier nicht drei
national handeln sondern im europäischen
Verbund es macht keinen Sinn dass wir
uns jetzt gegenseitig zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich mit den
Italienern auch noch den
rohstoffwettbewerb ausliefern sondern
hier müssen wir gemeinsam an einem
Strang ziehen und deswegen haben wir
deutsch-französisch ein Input in den
europäischen Prozess gegeben das ist für
mich der richtige Ansatz hier gibt es
nur eine europäische Antwort die wir
auch gemeinsam gut vorbereiten
und zweitens Recycling Recycling
Recycling das haben sie vorhin selber
angesprochen der Wohnhaus wir haben hier
Recyclingquoten die sind ja wirklich
nicht akzeptabel dafür dass diese
Rohstoffe so wertvoll sind müssen wir
hier dringend Vorankommen dafür werden
wir auch bei uns bei den Normen
Standards wo nötig rechtliche Grundlagen
verbessern um das in Deutschland und in
Europa voranzubringen wir brauchen mehr
Forschung herolf sie haben es richtig
angesprochen ja da gibt es tolle neue
Technologien für die Substitution für
die Effizienz die müssen wir fördern und
voranbringen da sind ganz neue
Möglichkeiten das ist die Zukunft ja und
da rein müssen wir jetzt auch
entsprechend investieren dritter Punkt
die Versorgungssicherheit rückt auch die
heimische Gewinnung von Rohstoffen in
den Fokus das gehört dazu und hier
führen wir einen Dialog eine
gesellschaftliche Debatte um mehr
Akzeptanz des heimischen Rohstoffs auch
zu fördern das ist eine schwierige
Debatte und wir werden sie gut führen
dass wir am Ende eine höhere Akzeptanz
dafür haben es ist nämlich darum dass
wir international die Partnerschaften
haben dass wir bei dem Recycling
Vorankommen die Stoffe die schon bei uns
sind sie besser noch mal immer wieder
nutzen und drittens beim heimischen
Rohstoffabbau mit ökologisch hohen
Standards auch unseren Beitrag zur
Rohstoffversorgung sichern das sind die
drei Schritte die drei Pfeiler einer
unserer aktiven Rohstoffpolitik und wenn
die Opposition dabei mitmacht dann freue
ich mich darüber und lade Sie ein
herzlich mitzumachen herzlichen Dank ich
freue mich auf eine aktive neue
Rohstoffpolitik die wir als Deutschland
endlich voranbringen können danke
ich komme nochmals zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt
26c die Zeit der namentlichen Abstimmung
ist jetzt vorbei
ich schließe jetzt diese ich schließe
die Abstimmung und ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
damit komme ich zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 27 und nächster
Redner für die Fraktion DIE LINKE ist
Christian Laier
ist wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der
Linksfraktion und das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung zur einem
weiteren Aufheben der Schuldenbremse für
die für den 200 Milliarden Euro
Rettungsschirm werden wir so in gut 10
bis 15 Minuten bekommen es geht um eine
extrem hohe Abhängigkeit bei Rohstoffen
Deutschland ist der fünftgrößte
rohstoffverbraucher der Welt und mehr
als 99 Prozent der im Bergbau gewonnenen
Metalle kommen aus dem Ausland und dann
wird im unionsantrag etwas nebulös von
geopolitischen Spannungen gesprochen und
ich sage reden wir doch offen über die
beiden Elefanten im Raum das ist die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit von Russland und
das ist die Rohstoffabhängigkeit von
China zu Russland 44 Prozent der
Deutschen Nickel und palladiumimporte 41
Prozent der titanimporte und 22 Prozent
des rohraluminiums kommen aus Russland
und deswegen stehen diese und weitere
Rohstoffe auch aus guten Grund nicht auf
der eu-sanktionsliste im Übrigen genauso
wenig wie das Gas aber was wir im
laufenden Wirtschaftskrieg gemeinsam
gelernt haben ist die Gegenseite schlägt
dort zurück wo sie es sich aussucht das
können wir uns nicht aussuchen sie
schlägt dort zu wo es weh tut wie wir an
den aktuellen Energiepreisen merken
meine Damen und Herren
so und dann reden wir über den zweiten
Elefanten im Raum das ist die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit von China es gibt
eine Reihe von relevanten Rohstoffen wo
wir bis zu 100 Prozent von chinesischen
Importen abhängig sind und im Gegensatz
zu Russland bleibt diese Abhängigkeit
auch längerfristig ein Problem und zwar
weil fast die Hälfte der weltweiten
bergbauproduktion von China betrieben
wird das lässt sich nicht einfach so weg
diversifizieren meine Damen und Herren
so und warum sage ich das weil sich im
Zuge der Rivalität mit China auch die
Wirtschaftspolitik verschärft im
klassischen Imperialismus galt noch the
Flag follows the trade heißt staatliche
Aktionen orientierten sich am
ökonomischen Handel heute im Niedergang
der westlichen Hegemonie gilt andersrum
the trade follows the Flag heißt
Handelskonflikte orientieren sich an
geopolitischen Konflikten und da stehen
wir möglicherweise auch bei China vor
die USA hat bereits ein halbleit Embargo
gegen China fängt und
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat in treuer
gefolter Gefolgschaft eine robustere
Handelspolitik gegenüber China
angekündigt ich kann nur eines sagen wir
sind gut beraten die Finger von einem
weiteren Wirtschaftskrieg zu lassen
diesmal mit China meine Damen und Herren
und dafür gibt es Gründe unsere
Abhängigkeit von vielen mineralischen
Rohstoffen aus China ist größer als die
von Gas aus Russland und was der
laufende Wirtschaftskrieg in der
Bevölkerung schon anrichtet da sehen wir
doch hoffentlich meine Damen und Herren
und ähnlich wie im Wirtschaftskrieg mit
Russland gilt diesmal es gibt kaum ein
Land in der EU das so abhängig ist von
Handel mit China wie Deutschland
deswegen darf man da nicht blindlings in
den nächsten Wirtschaftskrieg
hineinlaufen ich sage Ihnen noch ein
Handelskonflikt und diesmal ein härterer
und schlimmerer als der mit Russland das
wird die Bevölkerung nicht mitmachen das
hält die nicht aus meine Damen und
Herren
und es gibt noch einen weiteren Grund
sie wollen die Abhängigkeit von
russischen gasreduzieren und erneuerbare
Energien ausbauen aber deswegen wird die
Abhängigkeit von chinesischen Rohstoffen
ansteigen und warum bei seltenen Erden
sind wir zu 100 Prozent auf chinesische
Importe angewiesen die braucht man aber
für Solaranlagen und Windkraftanlagen
bei Graphit sind wir zu 90 Prozent auf
chinesische Importe angewiesen die
braucht man aber auch für Solaranlagen
und bei Gallium sind wir zu 60% auf
chinesische Importe angewiesen und auch
das braucht man für die Solarindustrie
das heißt die Nachfrage nach Öl und Gas
wird langfristig sinken aber die
Abhängigkeit von Metallen und Erden wird
genau deswegen ansteigen für das
Industriezeitalter waren fossile
Brennstoffe die Treiber aber in der
Energiewende und in der Digitalisierung
braucht es jetzt mehr Kobalt Lithium
Seltene Erden und so weiter und so fort
und deswegen jetzt am Ende noch mal
langsam zum Mitschreiben die
wirdifizierung Kreislaufwirtschaft
Recycling alles richtig alles wichtig
lassen sie um Gottes Willen die Finger
von einem weiteren Wirtschaftskrieg mit
China die Bevölkerung wird das nicht
mittragen sie gefährden Digitalisierung
sie gefährden die Energiewende und sie
gefährden die Klimaziele dankeschön
Christian leyhe für die Linksfraktion wo
er wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher ist
in dieser Debatte in der es um
Deutschlands Rohstoff Abhängigkeit geht
aber auch im Strategien diese Rohstoffe
zu sichern durch Partnerschaften
beispielsweise und dazu jetzt Reinhard
Huben aus der FDP-Fraktion auch er ist
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte doch auf die Vorräte ein
bisschen Eingehen
auf kennen sie als seriösen Abgeordneten
der sich einbringt in die Themen die er
vorträgt und deswegen sage ich zum
ersten ihr Antrag hat
Aspekte die wir gerne debattieren wollen
also deswegen vielen Dank für diese
Begleitung und da sage ich immer
andersrum eines Prozesses den die
Bundesregierung im Grunde ja schon
längst angestoßen hat also deswegen wir
können gerne debattieren ich halte es
für ein wichtiges Thema sie haben das
richtig dargestellt und Rohstoffpolitik
hat vor allen Dingen eine
Langfristperspektive und ich möchte nur
eine Bemerkung zur letzten
Legislaturperiode machen aus welchen
Gründen auch immer
ist eben in der letzten
Legislaturperiode in dem Bereich
ja fast gar nichts passiert
und so ist das mit dem Timing von
Anträgen manchmal komme ich auch nicht
so ganz
zeitlich geschickt
ich bin gestern später da gewesen ich
weiß nicht ob sie da waren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der unionfraktion der
BDI hat gestern Abend eine glaube
fünfstündige Veranstaltung zum Thema
Rohstoffe gemacht und dort hat unter
anderem der Wirtschaftsminister selbst
gesprochen da war ich auch noch nicht
anwesend aber Frau Brantner hat dann in
einer Debatte für die Bundesregierung
Stellung genommen und ich sage Ihnen
dort hat sich die Bundesregierung
positioniert zu dem was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben wir
haben nämlich im Koalitionsvertrag eines
festgestellt
wir können nicht einerseits sagen wir
wollen Industriestandort bleiben
und gleichzeitig erwarten dass andere
Länder zu möglichst günstigen Preisen
und waren und Rohstoffe liefern wir aber
andererseits sozusagen im eigenen
Vorgarten nicht bereit sind
entsprechende Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und
das haben wir in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen erkannt und auch
so formuliert und das fängt natürlich
bei der Kiesgrube an
endet aber meine Damen und Herren weil
Seltene Erden angesprochen worden sind
es gibt Aktivitäten im Erzgebirge um
seltene Erden vorkommen die wir in
Deutschland haben zu heben und dann ist
es unsere Aufgabe die Rahmenbedingungen
zu schaffen dass diese Maßnahmen in
Deutschland erfolgreich schnell aber
eben auch umweltverträglich umgesetzt
werden und das ist unser Ziel
und noch mal zu den Ausführungen
Rohstoffabhängigkeit
das ist aber doch im Grunde deutsche
Realität seit 200 Jahren seit dem
Deutschland
Industrie Land geworden ist waren wir
immer abhängig von Rohstofflieferung ja
wir hatten vor allen Dingen Steinkohle
Braunkohle und Ärzte für Stahl
aber eben andere Rohstoffe noch nie also
wenn dann Kautschuk zum Beispiel als
Beispiel für
Rohstoffmangel vorgegeben wird Herr
Kollege muss ich sagen ich habe noch nie
einen Kautschukbaum in Deutschland
wachsen sehen aber das ist vielleicht
eine andere Kleinigkeit und eine
Bemerkung noch zu den weltpolitischen
Bedingungen
meine Damen und Herren hier in diesem
Hohen Hause wenn es einen
Handelskonflikt mit China geben wird
dann werden wir den hier nicht auslösen
das wird auch nicht die Europäische
Union sein das wird ganz alleine davon
abhängen wie sich Peking in Zukunft
verhält vor allen Dingen im Verhältnis
zu teilbar
und
meine Damen und Herren da geht es aber
auch nicht um die Frage ob wir gewinnen
oder verlieren ich weiß ja nicht wie Sie
das sehen aber ich finde wir haben eine
gewisse politisch moralische
Verpflichtung freie Demokratien zu
verteidigen so wie wir das im Moment mit
der Ukraine tun und so werden wir es
dann in Zukunft auch tun müssen
meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung ist
in der Arbeit Frau Brandner hat das
dargestellt sie sammelt im Moment ganz
schön viele bonusmalen wenn ich das so
richtig verstanden habe um weltweit
Partnerschaften voranzubringen wir sind
unterwegs mit den unterschiedlichsten
Handelsverträgen um die
Rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern und
jetzt wird die Union wieder sagen wann
wird denn ceta ratifiziert da gilt immer
doch das Wort von Bernd Westphal in
diesem Herbst also meine Damen und
Herren die Bundesregierung ist aktiv
Rohstoffe sind ein langfrist-thema wir
haben damit begonnen und werden es
langfristig nicht nur mit ausländischen
Partnern sondern auch hier in
Deutschland lösen vielen Dank
Reinhard Huben der wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte
zu zwei Anträgen aus cdu/csu und
afd-fraktion zur Rohstoffe Sicherung in
Deutschland drei Säulen hat die
Rohstoffversorgung in Deutschland einmal
die Sicherung und Ausbeute heimischer
Rohstoffe dann geht es um Importe und
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt und der auch
noch weiter nach vorne rücken soll sind
ist das Recycling von Rohstoffen
Bernhard Loos für die Unionsfraktion für
den Standort Deutschland von
herausragender Bedeutung unsere
Rohstoffversorgung steht auf drei Säulen
die auch in einer Rohstoffstrategie eine
zentrale Rolle spielen muss
ersten förderungheimische Rohstoffe
zweitens Import von benötigten
Rohstoffen sowie Gewinnung von
sekundarrohstoffen durch Recycling
mit unserem Antrag wollen wir auf einige
grundlegende Entwicklungen reagieren
erhebliche nachfrageveränderungen
Zunahme von Handelsstreitigkeiten
Marktverzerrungen durch staatliche
Eingriffe und dominieren die Marktmacht
einzelne Erzeuger oder Erzeuger Länder
im Jahr 2011 hatte die damalige
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung der
deutschen rohstoffagentur beauftragt ein
rohstoffmonitoring zu kritischen
Rohstoffen zu entwickeln die Unternehmen
regelmäßig auf Preis und liefert Risiken
hinzuweisen bei der Erstellung der
Ausweichstrategien mitzuhelfen dieser
Ansatz muss weiter ausgebaut werden
in der nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie
müssen konkret die Maßnahmen benannt
werden mit denen eine sichere und
bezahlbare Rohstoffversorgung
gewährleistet werden sollen
der FAZ vom 17.10 22 konnten wir
entnehmen dass Deutschland eine
wirtschaftssicherheitspolitik braucht so
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin dr
Brandner
wenn dies heißt gemeinsam mit der
europäischen Partnern gemeinsam mit der
Industrie entsprechende Vorsorge zu
treffen dann unterstützen wir dies
wir wollen auch das geprüftort ob die
Einführung einer Rohstoff
bevorratungsrücklage die Resilienz von
Unternehmen
gegenüberlieferketten Unterbrechungen
stärken wurde wir wollen aber nicht dass
die Überlegungen der Bundesregierung
bedeuten könnten dass man der Industrie
vorschreiben will was in welchem Umfang
wie zu bevorraten wäre
Deutschland ist bei vielen Rohstoffen
zumeist vollständig auf den Import
angewiesen wir müssen daher verstärkt
daran arbeiten alternative
Versorgungsmöglichkeiten zu erschließen
die Substitution von primär durch
Sekundärrohstoffe muss hierzu einen
wichtigen Beitrag leisten die in
Deutschland bereits hochentwickelte
Kreislaufwirtschaft soll sich zukünftig
noch entschiedener am Leitbild der
ressourceneffizienz-versorgung der
deutschen Wirtschaft ausrichten
wichtig aus unserer Sicht den Austausch
zwischen Industrieforschung und
Verwaltung zu verbessern um die
Gewinnung und Nutzung von sekundären
Rohstoffen gezielt voran zu bringen den
Entsorgungswirtschaft selbst
stellt bereits gut 15 Prozent der in
Deutschland benötigten Rohstoffe bereit
durch den Rückgriff auf
Sekundärrohstoffe werden jährlich
Rohstoffimporte mit einem Wert von mehr
als 10 Milliarden Euro eingespart
Verantwortung für eine gesicherte
Rohstoffversorgung heißt aber auch bei
uns im eigenen Land Rohstoffe abzubauen
und nicht nur im Ausland zu beschaffen
es braucht ein größeres Engagement bei
der Gewinnung von Rohstoffen im Inland
die Ampelkoalition hat im
Koalitionsvertrag vor einem Jahr
folgende schöne zwei Sätze geschrieben
wir wollen unsere Wirtschaft bei der
Sicherung einer macht nachhaltigen
Rohstoffversorgung unterstützen den
heimischen rohstoffaufbau erleichtern
und ökologisch ausrichten wir wollen das
bundesbankgesetz modernisieren
aber aber herum was ist bisher gesehen
und wo überhaupt soll die Reise hingehen
das fragen sich nicht nur die
betreffenden Unternehmen zum Bereichen
gibt es zum Beispiel im Bereich der
gipsindustrie Fakt ist
Reha Gips hat aktuell einen Anteil von
nur noch ca 55% im Deutschen gibt es
rohstoff-mix ein verstärktes Recycling
wurde die gesamte Thematik mengenmäßig
nur etwa zehn Prozent entlasten ebenso
wenig können Importe die entstehenden
Versorgungslücken ausgleichen deshalb
bedarf es sowohl der neu Erschließung
von gipsabbauflächen als auch der
Beseitigung bestehende Hindernisse bei
erforderlichen produktsteigerungen
existierenden gewinnungsarealen
Verantwortung für eine Energieversorgung
heißt zu prüfen ob und wie wir in
Deutschland mehr Öl und Gas gewinnen
können und eben nicht nur fracking-gas
in den USA Einkaufen nach dem Motto aus
den Augen aus dem Sinn
dazu gehört es eine neue
Genehmigung für die Offshore-Förderung
von Öl und Erdgas jenseits der erteilten
Rahmen
Betriebserlaubnisse zu ermöglichen und
das Verbot von kommerzieller
unkonventioneller frackingvorhaben auf
Basis des Berichts der
Expertenkommission Fracking zeitnah zu
evaluieren den Kurswechsel des grünen
Bundeswirtschaftsministers ging dem
Wortlaut gegen den Wortlaut der des
ampelkoalitionsvertrages in Sachen
nordsee-gasforderung und die positiven
Signale zu schaffen der
völkerrechtlichen Voraussetzung
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich ich betone
aber auch es darf keine Rückschritte
durch eine neue rot-grüne
Landesregierung in Niedersachsen geben
das wäre das falsche Signal ich danke
Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Bernhard los aus der Unionsfraktion
gebe aber bevor ich dem nächsten Redner
das Wort gebe noch bekannt wie die
Abstimmung ausgegangen ist
der Beschluss des Deutschen Bundestages
gemäß Artikel 115 absatz 2 Satz 6 und 7
des Grundgesetzes abgegeben wurden 665
Stimmkarten mit ja haben gestimmt 390
mit Nein 239 36 haben sich enthalten
gemäß Artikel 15 Absatz 2 seit 6 ist
Grundgesetzes ist die Mehrheit der
Mitglieder erforderlich das sind 369 ja
stimmen der Antrag ist mit der
erforderlichen Mehrheit angenommen
und die Anzahl der
zustimmenden liebten relativ naja sogar
im oberen Bereich zu dem was möglich
gewesen wäre maximal 416 Stimmen bringt
ja die Ampel Koalition hier auf die
Waage das heißt damit ist auch gleich
klar nach Ende dieser Debatte die im
Moment noch läuft wird dann aufgerufen
die Abstimmung über das über den über
die Gesetzesänderung zum
stabilisierungsfongesetz zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds zunächst
Michael Tews aus der SPD-Fraktion in der
Debatte über Rohstoffe
um Rohstoffabbau um jeden Preis
Nachhaltigkeit Fehlanzeige Menschen
würde Menschenrechte Fehlanzeige und
Umweltschutz sowieso Fehleranzeige so
kann man nachhaltige Umweltpolitik
nachhaltige Rohstoffpolitik auf keinen
Fall machen da sind die Unternehmen und
die Menschen in Deutschland schon längst
weiter
das können nicht die Antworten sein
insbesondere auch nicht in so einer
Krise man kann mit den Ideen von
vorgestern nicht die Probleme von morgen
lösen wir werden innovative Lösungen
brauchen und da bietet Deutschland
einiges insbesondere im Bereich der
Kreislaufwirtschaft und schade dass sie
da eben diesen Lösungen nicht mehr Raum
eingeräumt haben auch in ihren Anträgen
in Deutschland kann da eine ganze Menge
mehr passieren wir müssen Transformation
voranbringen Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft hin zu einer
Kreislaufwirtschaft und das ganze so
schnell wie möglich die Menge an
abgebauten Rohstoffen auf dieser Welt
ist nun mal oder abbaubaren Rohstoffen
ist begrenzt gleichzeitig aber steigt
der Ressourcenbedarf rasant an 2016 wird
der voraussichtlich doppelt so hoch sein
wie 2011 haben wir noch 2011 79
Gigatonnen Material Materialien
verbraucht werden es 2016 schon 167 sein
und statt jetzt nun versuchen zu
versuchen einen Kampf um Rohstoffe vom
Zaun zu brechen und dort Lösungen zu
finden wäre es dringend geboten
Kreislaufwirtschaft wirklich jetzt neu
zu denken voranzubringen aus
ökonomischen aber natürlich auch aus
ökologischen Gründen
der Abbau von primären Rohstoffen
versucht verursacht nahezu immer mehr
Treibhausgase als ein Recyclingprozess
ein bekanntes Beispiel ist Aluminium für
Recycling von Aluminium benötigt man nur
fünf Prozent der Energiemenge wie für
die Herstellung aus primärrohstoffbau
kriegt europaweit werden im stofflichen
Recycling jährlich über 100 Millionen
Megawattstunden primär Energie
eingespart dazu kommt dass der Abbau und
die Verarbeitung von Rohstoffen heute
bereits für 90 Prozent der Bio des
Verlustes an Biodiversität
verantwortlich ist
Kreislaufwirtschaft und das ist meine
feste Überzeugung ist eben gelebter
Klima und Umweltschutz und schafft
Unabhängigkeit von den volontiven
volantilen Märkten aber auch
Unabhängigkeit in Krisensituationen wie
wir das jetzt erleben und deswegen
glaube ich dass wir im Bereich der
Kreislaufwirtschaft noch viel
Möglichkeiten haben hier Lösungen zu
finden
die Europa Europäische Union importiert
78 Prozent des benötigten Lithium aus
einem einzigen Land wir haben das vorhin
schon gehört aus Chile
diese Abhängigkeit sollte anders genug
sein das Lithium Recycling in
Deutschland mit Hochdruck voranzutreiben
die Industrie ist Deutsch in Deutschland
setzt bisher nur 12 Prozent Rohstoffe
aus recyclingprozessen ein das müssen
wir dringend ändern wir müssen
Produkte recyclingfähig herstellen wir
brauchen eine einsatzquote für retiklate
und Liebe Union das haben sie jahrelang
verhindert und immer dagegen gesprochen
wir müssen durch geeignete
Rahmenbedingungen die Absatz von
rezikaten und sekundärmaterialien
fördern und dadurch eine
Investitionssicherheit für
kreislaufwirtschaftsunternehmen schaffen
das alles sind Maßnahmen für die sich
die SPD-Fraktion schon lange einsetzt
und die Union immer wieder blockiert hat
da wurde das nicht dass die Förderung
der Kreislaufwirtschaft in ihrem Antrag
ganz hinten vorkommt ich hoffe dass es
keine Wertung der Kreislaufwirtschaft
denn das hätte sie nicht verdient
die Union hatte den letzten Jahren
Maßnahmen zur Förderung der
Kreislaufwirtschaft immer wieder mit dem
Hinweis blockiert man dürfe die
Wirtschaft nicht zu sehr belasten man
müsste auf die EU warten und nur eins zu
eins umsetzen das sind verpasste Chancen
vor allen Dingen
und das zeigt auch eigentlich ihr Antrag
die Anträge die uns vorliegen die sind
rückwärts gewarnt und wenig innovativ
vielen Dank
dann müsste jetzt auch klatschen
ja so schnell kann es gehen mit einem
Redebeitrag Michael Tews war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion nächster Redner Werte sein
Bernd Schattner aus der afd-fraktion die
ja ebenfalls einen Antrag hier vorgelegt
hat die nachhaltige Sicherung und
Versorgung mit strategischen Rohstoffen
ist das Rückgrat einer Industrienation
wie Deutschlands der hier vorliegende
Antrag der Union hat allerdings mal
wieder einige Lücken und Widersprüche
sie wollen zum einen
rohstoffpartnerschaften identifizieren
ausbauen und neu abschließen tragen aber
gleichzeitig die für Deutschland
desaströsesanktionspolitik gegen
Russland als größten rohstoffexporteur
der Welt mit
gleichzeitig schreiben sie in ihrem
Antrag dass sie ihn Erwägung ziehen
umweltschädliches Fracking in
Deutschland zu betreiben um auf der
anderen Seite die Rohstoffgewinnung im
Zuge der Transformation hin zu
Klimaneutralität zu unterstützen was
darf es denn jetzt bitte davon sein
meine Damen und Herren mehr Heuchelei
geht doch gar nicht sie belügen den
Wähler bewusst und in voller Absicht sie
wollen anders sein sie wollen eine
Opposition sein sie sind weder anders
geschweige denn eine echte Situation in
ihrer Regierungsverantwortung besiegen
sie die Kohle und Atomausstieg und
unterstützten Werte die man als
linksgrün aber definitiv nicht als
konservativen Politik bezeichnen kann
für uns als AFD steht aktuell fest
deutsche Energie und Strom geht nur mit
Kohle und Atom ihr Antrag ist immer gut
gemeint aber handwerklich schlecht
gemacht denn er versucht nur die
Symptome zu lindern traut sich aber
nicht an die Ursachen heran es spricht
für sich dass diejenigen die immer
wieder von sich als Volksparteien
sprechen immer stärker gegen das
deutsche Volk agieren statt des Versuchs
eine diplomatische Lösung in dem Krieg
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine zu
finden wählen Sie den Weg einer weiteren
Eskalation sie sind auf der Seite derer
die weiter Waffen und andere
rüstungsglieder und die Kriegsgebiete
liefern wollen und tragen damit massiv
zur Eskalation bei der Lösungsweg von
uns als der AFD ist ein anderer wir
versuchen immer wieder die
Bundesregierung zu einer diplomatischen
Option zu bewegen leider besetzt umsonst
für uns überraschend ist vor allem die
Position der Grünen als angebliche
Konfliktparteien diesen als
Friedenspartei in diesem Konflikt töten
sie im Wahlkampf noch groß mit Sprüchen
wie keine Waffen in Kriegsgebiete so
liefern sie heute nicht nur in die
Ukraine sondern weiterhin auch an
Staaten die zum Beispiel Saudi-Arabien
aber in Sachen Doppelmoral kennen sie
sich ja wunderbar aus wenn sie genauso
viel Energie in die Bewältigung der
Strom und der Gaskrise investieren
würden wie beim Feiern nach ihrem
Parteitag müssten die deutschen
Steuerzahler die diese Party
finanzierten weder frieren noch Angst um
ihren Wohlstand haben meine Damen und
Herren Rohstoffe wie Gas und Öl zu
bezahlbaren Preisen sind momentan nur
mit einem fairen Handel mit Russland zu
erreichen mit teuren Importen aus den
USA und Katar machen wir uns nur noch
abhängiger als wäre es jetzt schon sind
liebe Kollegen gestatten Sie mir am Ende
meiner Rede noch ein paar Worte zu den
Ereignissen in Ludwigshafen bei mir in
meinem Heimatort ich danke meinem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden kinopropalla dass
er in seiner gestrigen Rede bereits den
beiden ermordeten Handwerkern gedacht
hat als Reinhard Felser ist es für mich
das Schweigen der Landesregierung und
allen voran Ministerpräsidentin
Marie-Luise Dreier jedoch das
enttäuschend die überhaupt ein weiteres
mal versagt sie bei einer Tragödie ich
mag mir gar nicht vorstellen wie die
Reaktion ausgefallen wäre wenn es sich
bei den beiden ermordeten eben nicht um
zwei deutsche Handwerker gehandelt hätte
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort gebe ich an die Kollegen Dr
Sandra detzer für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und sie ist Mitglied im
Wirtschaftsausschuss
[Applaus]
Pferde
Renten liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
es dann der Kollege Huben hat schon
gesagt haben wir sehr sehr interessante
diskutiert auf dem rohstoffkongress des
BUND der deutschen Industrie des BDI
ganz breit war Unternehmer innen war
Politik war Zivilgesellschaft vertreten
und es war vollkommen klar dass sich
alle einig sind auch die zeitenwände ist
bei der Rohstoffpolitik angekommen die
internationalen Rohstoffmärkte und das
ist glaube ich ganz zentral diesen Punkt
wirklich auch gerade aus unionssicht mal
durchzudenken
die internationalen Rohstoffmärkte
Stellen eben nicht mehr zu jeder Zeit
die gebrauchten Rohstoffe zur Verfügung
und wenn Sie das dann doch tun dann eben
nicht zu Preisen die wettbewerbsfähig
sind für unsere Industrie und genau
diese
Verfügbarkeit auf diese Preisstabilität
die brauchen wir natürlich das haben wir
jetzt gesehen dass das beim Gas des
Problem ist und es gilt ganz besonders
natürlich im Punkto kritische im Punkto
strategische Rohstoffe die wir jetzt
brauchen für die Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft da geht es um Lithium
Magnesium Kobalt die Vorredner erinnern
haben das aufgezählt das bedeutet aber
auch es ist Zeit für eine echte
Rohstoffstrategie in Deutschland und vor
allen Dingen in Europa wir diskutieren
in Europa momentan sehr sehr viel über
die Frage gemeinsamer Gaseinkauf
gemeinsame Gaspreise das ist im Kern
auch die künftige Debatte die wir über
Rohstoffe führen werden und ich bin der
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärin
Brandtag extrem dankbar dass sie dann
klugen Vorschlag gemacht hat zusammen
Frankreich wie wir in der Sache
weiterkommen können weil das ist genau
das wie die Operationalisierung auch
dieses deutsch-französischen Motors
funktionieren kann
und warum ist das jetzt so wichtig und
das ist glaube ich auch ein Punkt der
ein bisschen unterbelichtet ist im
unionsantrag warum brauchen wir diese
Rohstoff Souveränität weil wir wissen
dass wir Mittelstand dass wir unsere
Wirtschaft aber auch unsere Gesellschaft
besser schützen müssen vor massiven
Krisen das ist in der Vergangenheit
leider nicht genug passiert wir haben
leider gesehen dass ich ganz viele
politische Akteure darauf verlassen
haben eben dass der Weltmarkt diese
Rohstoffe zur Verfügung stellt und genau
deswegen ist diese Rohstoff Souveränität
der zentral
an der Stelle fragt mich übrigens sehr
gefreut dass sie die jobmac erwähnt
haben die japanische rohstoff-agentur
Japan ist uns meines Erachtens ungefähr
zehn Jahre in der rohstoffsuveränität
voraus Japan hatte die Zeitenwende
bereits 2010 china hat damals die
Einfuhr der seltenen Erden nach Japan
gestoppt und daraufhin hat die
japanische Regierung sich sehr sehr
kluge Gedanken gemacht über Rohstoff
Souveränität ich habe gestern und seit
längeren Tagen viel geredet mit der BGR
mit der deutschen rohstoffagentur derer
und die haben gesagt Mensch wir warnen
seit Jahren fast schon seit Jahrzehnten
vor Klumpenrisiko bei der
Rohstoffbeschaffung wir sind immer gegen
geschlossene Türen gelaufen es hat nicht
funktioniert davon was umzusetzen jetzt
ist es endlich soweit Rohstoffe sondern
aller Munde und das ist die gute
Nachricht wir haben hier in Windows
opportunity
Frau Kollegin sie kommen zum Ende bitte
zum Schluss niemand muss globalen
partner:innen aber auch
Wettbewerberinnen böses unterstellen und
es ist ganz klar dass wir für eine faire
Globalisierung so viel Kooperationen wie
möglich brauchen doch die Situation ist
Ernst der chinesische Marktanteil bei
den Rohstoffen ist zu hoch und deswegen
ist es gut dass rohstoffsouveränität das
Gebot der Stunde ist herzlichen Dank
sandra derzer hat ein wenig ihre Zeit
überzogen aber wir nutzen trotzdem die
Gelegenheit Ihnen schnell zu sagen was
sie denn mit BGR eben gemeint hat da
haben wir nämlich fix nachgeguckt das
ist die Bundesanstalt für
Geowissenschaften und Rohstoffe nicht
ganz unwichtig in dieser Debatte und
jetzt ist Hagen Reinhold dran aus der
FDP-Fraktion
beauftragt dafür maritime Wirtschaft
auch da gibt es ja tief im Meer durchaus
wichtige Rohstoffe ich beginne die meine
Rede damit was zu beleuchten was wir
noch gar nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm
haben wir reden nämlich sehr oft davon
was wir für Rohstoffe jetzt gerade
brauchen und versuchen so in die Zukunft
zu schauen ich prognostizier uns mal wie
wissen noch nicht wie der rohstoffmix in
zehn Jahren aussieht und das auch gut
und richtig so
warum sage ich das weil wir wenn wir
dieses Haus betrachten in den letzten
Jahren ganz andere Debatten haben noch
vor zwei Jahren Entschuldigung noch vor
zwei Jahren haben wir über Holz und
sandknappheit hier diskutiert die
Rohstoffstrategie die letzte ist gerade
mal zwei Jahre her 2020 das Wort Erdgas
steht dreimal drin und zwar im
Zusammenhang mit wir haben langfristige
Lieferverträge und deshalb
versorgensicherheit in Deutschland daran
sieht man schon es ändert sich was und
was brauchen wir dazu Forschung und
Entwicklung warum nämlich dann eine
Wirtschaft die selbst verstanden hat
dass eine immer höhere Nachfrage auf
immer knappere einzelne Materialien
stößt eine schlechte Zukunftsperspektive
hat und deshalb gibt es ja Leute die
sagen lasst uns doch aus Lithium in den
Akkus andere Materialien verwenden und
deshalb sind wir längst auf den Weg bei
Forschung und Entwicklung hin zu
Materialien die eine größere
Verfügbarkeit haben und auch eine
heimischee Verfügbarkeit und deshalb
schreibt sich diese
fortschrittsregierung nämlich auch
Forschung und Entwicklung auf ihre
Fahnen ist ein Teil der Lösung die wir
brauchen
ich komme mal zu einem bemerkenswert war
eine Fraktion hat versucht
herauszufinden wie das funktioniert für
die nächsten Jahre vorauszuschauen und
das ist hier die Alternative für
Russland hier ist ja auch kein Wunder
eigentlich denn die haben sich ja von
Russland und von China haben sie auch in
ihrer Rede klar gemacht noch deutlich
mehr abgeguckt als wir bisher gedacht
haben nämlich wir können ein sehr
planwirtschaftlichen Ansatz nehmen das
sind Länder die das machen und das haben
sich abgeschaut und die wollen jetzt
nämlich die Bundesregierung auffordern
zu defanieren welche Gewerbe Zweige in
Deutschland in der Wirtschaft welche
Rohstoffe vorzuliefer und Endprodukte
für die nächsten Jahre brauchen das
wollen sie festschreiben das kann man
machen in Ländern die Erfolg Knechten da
kann man nämlich sagen wir bauen in den
nächsten fünf Jahren so und so viel
Autos und so viel Motorroller so zu mir
Waschmaschinen dann klappt das in einem
Land wie Deutschland was innovativ ist
was fortschrittlich ist klappt
Planwirtschaft nicht deshalb ist ihr
Antrag unsinnig und mehr nicht
sie sprechen davon dass wir in den
Ländern von denen wir Rohstoffe beziehen
tätig werden sollen das machen wir
längst mit
wirtschaftspartnerschaftsabkommen der EU
die nehme ich ungleichgewichtig darauf
achten wie wir mit Ländern umgehen indem
wir zum Beispiel kleineren Ländern
Zollfreiheit in die EU gewährleisten
während sie bei uns zu einer nehmen
können und warum machen wir das
europäisch und nicht so wie sie in ihren
Antrag schreiben wir sollen das
nationalstaatlich in Deutsch machen weil
kluge Gründungsväter der europäischen
der Europäischen Union längst erkannt
haben in Europa gibt es nur zwei Typen
von Staaten kleine Staaten und solche
die noch nicht verstanden haben dass sie
klein sind deshalb schließen wir uns
zusammen und Handeln europäisch weil nur
so solche Abgaben durchzusetzen ist das
macht auch wenn man mal schaut werden
wir über seltene Ebene reden das ist
schon angeklungen selten haben wir auch
bei uns
Seltene Erden haben wir auch bei uns
aber die Veredelungsprozesse haben ihnen
starke Auswirkungen auf Menschen und
Umwelt und genau das ist der Grund warum
wir mit lieferkettengesetzen überprüfen
wollen wo wir sie herbekommen ist
übrigens auch der Grund warum wir sie
nicht in Europa produzieren obwohl wir
es könnten teilweise und deshalb ist
natürlich in einer Zeit die die
Unternehmen stark fordert zu
kontrollieren ob Lieferketten vielleicht
nicht ein zwei Jahre später zumindest so
umgesetzt werden wie sie vorgenommen
sind aber dass wir als Wirtschaftsnation
vorangehen und überprüfen ich habe dafür
keine toleranzia sie schreiben in ihrem
Antrag man sollte akzeptieren was in den
Ländern passiert gesellschaftlich und
auch arbeitstechnisch und nennen das
Toleranz also ich nenne Kinderarbeit
oder ich habe für Kinderarbeit weder
Toleranz noch sonst irgendwas übrig und
Lehne deshalb das ab
lassen Sie mich die letzten Sekunden
dafür verwenden zu sagen dass im
unionsantrag B1 aufgefallen ist nämlich
die fehlende Diskussion mit der
Wirtschaft zusammen für Rohstoffe zu
sorgen dafür hatten kluger liberale
Wirtschaftsminister mal die Deutsche
rohstoffagentur unter anderem gegründet
um die Wirtschaft zu unterstützen und in
Gesetzesvorhaben wo sie es anprangern da
nimmt man sowas Verbandsanhörung und
Diskussion mit den unterschiedlichen
Akteuren das macht diese Bundesregierung
selbstverständlich deshalb ist ihr
Antrag in den Teilen die sie aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag abgeschlossen haben
sehr gut im Rest ausbeutwürdig danke
schön
und das war Hagen Reinhold aus der
FDP-Fraktion ihm wird jetzt folgen
Hans-peter Welsch aus der Fraktion CDU
CSU es geht weiter hier geht es
weiterhin um Rohstoffe und die
Abhängigkeit davon liebe Kollegen
die Ampel hat im Koalitionsvertrag ist
ja schon angesprochen worden verbesserte
Rahmenbedingungen für die Erkundung
heimischer Rohstoffe angekündigt das ist
also die Abteilung selbst gewinnen was
wir können aber bisher absolut keiner
Initiative auf den Weg gebracht in
dieser Richtung die Sicherungen der
Rohstoffversorgung ist essentiell für
unser Land und deshalb fordern wir von
der CDU CSU von dieser Regierung alle
Optionen müssen auf den Tisch und zwar
schnell
ein größeres Engagement Deutschlands bei
der Gewinnung von Rohstoffen im In- und
Ausland ist umgehend erforderlich neue
rohstoffpartnerschaften ist von Kollegen
schon ausgeführt worden enge
Zusammenarbeit mit den
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten in der Zugang zu
kritischen und strategisch wichtigen
Rohstoffen ist auch im Krisen und
Kriegsfall existenziell die
Energiemärkte sind weitgehend europäisch
und am Ende hängen wir alle an denselben
Brennstoffen für uns darf das nicht
bedeuten dass wir die Hände in den Schoß
legen
dass wir die Hände in den Schoß legen
sondern uns einfach darauf verlassen
dass die europäischen Partner oder die
USA im Ernstfall uns versorgen werden
wir müssen selbst vorsorgen und was
zählt ist die Tat Deutschland muss
seinen Beitrag leisten dass mehr es
mehreren sich die kritischen Stimmen bei
europäischen Partnern Deutschland muss
seinen Beitrag leisten als Gebot soll
ich europäischer Solidarität und eben
nicht mehr mit flatterstrom sondern mit
grundlastfähigen Energien und da ist von
dieser Regierung leider nichts zu
erwarten was wäre wenn Notfallpläne für
Lieferstopp gibt es nicht seit Monaten
ist klar im Bereich
Energieversorgung dass wir bis zum dass
wir zum Jahresende mit einer weiteren
Verknappung zu rechnen haben das Konzept
auf das wir warten heute morgen ist
diskutiert worden über 200 Milliarden
Überschriften nichts Konkretes ihr müsst
endlich mal aus dem Puschen kommen und
konkret was auf den Tisch legen was er
vorhabt in diesem Land
wenn man Beispiel nennen
bei den diesjährigen
Wirtschaftsgesprächen FAZ in Frankfurt
hat Christian Kullmann der evonik-chef
und Präsident des VCI die dramatische
Situation eine Beispiele Chemieindustrie
sehr passend beschrieben Frankfurt hatte
wenige Tage vorher in Europa Cup
gewonnen die Eintracht und da hat sich
das Bild eben aufgedrängt Strecke
Frankfurt Sevillas in 1830 km und
stellen sich vor und Zug der in
Frankfurt ankommt und dessen Ende noch
in Sevilla steht hat er die Frage den
Raum gestellt was glauben Sie wie lange
die deutsche chemische Industrie mit
diesen Zug voller gasdruckkesselwaggons
produzieren könnte sechs Stunden war die
Antwort sechs Stunden das zeigt das
Volumen was wir dort brauchen und wir
diskutieren das Ganze leider viel zu
viel zu sehr immer nur unter der
Überschrift in der das als Energieträger
für Chemie für Pharma für
düngemittelproduktion ist es
unverzichtbare produktionsrohstoff
und
da ist nicht nur hier beim Gas die
Abhängigkeit eben extrem hoch und damit
die erpresbarkeit sondern auch bei
Rohstoffen sie sind schon einige davon
ausgezählt worden aufgezählt worden
Silizium Kobalt Nickel auf
Herkunftsländer angewiesen deren innere
Verfasstheit häufig nicht gerade zum
Vorbild gereicht um es mal vor uns mal
vorsichtig auszudrücken
Abhängigkeit von mineralischen
Rohstoffen Seltene Erden insbesondere
China ist erwähnt worden wir haben jetzt
gesehen im Umgang mit Russland Putins
Clique
zögert nicht davor zurück Energie als
Waffe einzusetzen und ebenso würden die
Kommunisten in Peking nicht zögern ihre
wirtschaftliche Macht gegenüber
deutschen Unternehmen auszuspielen
Routine macht schon jetzt druckt bei
jeder sich bietenden Gelegenheit wenn
ihr irgendwas nicht passt reden sie mal
mit den Freunden in Litauen da können
Sie
interessante Geschichten erfahren wie
dort der Umgang zwischen Partnern im
außenwir Bereich ist
wir müssen aktiv in den weltweiten
Wettbewerb um die Rohstoffe einsteigen
Energiewende Digitalisierung steigern
die Nachfrage nach Rohstoffen drastisch
und gleichzeitig verschärft der Ukraine
kriegt die bereits vorhandenen
Lieferengpässe auch der links gelben
Ampel muss das langsam klar werden dass
ohne den Einsatz von vielfältigen von
vielfältigen Rohstoffen keine Produktion
keine Gebäude und kein Transport gibt
wenn die Ampel nicht bald initiativ wird
haben wir Stillstand in unserem ganzen
Land
die das hat nicht nur Auswirkungen das
hat nicht nur Auswirkungen auf
Arbeitsplätze Wohlstand das ist auch für
unsere Wehrhaftigkeit entscheidend ich
will Ihnen mal ein Beispiel nennen F35
haben sie gerade geschafft fünfte
Generation moderner Jet 700 Kilogramm
sogenannte selten Erdmetalle verarbeitet
darin das zeigt dass auch dort in der
Frage wie können wir unsere Sicherheit
garantieren dass ein wichtiger Punkt ist
der Wettlauf ist in vollem Gange und ich
hoffe dass schauen wir auf Lithium das
hier die Grünen auch bereits in wirklich
Schritte hier in Deutschland zu machen
wir wissen dass dieses begehrte Element
im Oberen Graben in salzigen thermal
Wasserreservoir in ansehnlicher Menge
vorhanden ist und das war alles nicht so
interessant bis silicium-ionen Batterien
sich durchgesetzt haben aber jetzt ist
es interessant und wir müssen daran
gehen und müssen das gewinnbar machen um
lithium-abhängigkeit vom Ausland zu
verringern
die die Themen kritische Rohstoff das
muss als als
strategisch wichtige wichtiges Thema für
die nationale Sicherheit begriffen
werden und da bin ich gespannt vor allen
Dingen auf die Grünen wie sie auch zum
Thema es ist eben viel von Recycling
gesprochen ist ja auch wichtig aber
natürlich müssen wir auch eigene
Ressourcen heben und wie da diejenigen
die ich immer nur erlebt habe als welche
die verhindern wollen Nord in my
backyard ist Prinzip ihrer Politik dass
wir dass wir dass wir das Erleben mit
ihnen da bin ich gespannt drauf ich bin
aus Hessen ich habe erlebt den ersten
Minister der Grünen Fischer
da bin ich gleich zu Ende wer hat als
erstes planmäßig die nuklearme Betriebe
Lösung und er hat als als nächstes sich
Produktion vorgenommen so arbeiten ich
bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit und
danke der Präsidentin für Ihre Geduld
na da verabschiedet er sich noch höflich
von der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt in die Zeit war
abgelaufen für Klaus Peter wohl willst
zumindest für diese Rewe hier in der
Debatte über Rohstoffabhängigkeit
nächster Redner banked aus der
SPD-Fraktion liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
eigentlich lohnt es sich ja kaum auf den
Antrag der AFD einzugehen der ist
technisch wieder mal schlecht gemacht
aber die Leute da draußen sollten
wirklich mal erfahren was das für eine
Truppe ist die hier sitzt die AFD
verbindet in perfider Weise jedes Ihrer
Anliegen mit der unerträglichen Hetze
gegen Andersdenkende und Andersgläubige
so verlangen sie dieses Mal allen
Ernstes wir sollen anderen Ländern keine
lgbtq-rechte aufzwingen und lokale
Kulturen einfach tolerieren gerade eben
wurde es schon gesagt
kinderarbeitsklaven aber das können wir
nicht tolerieren das zeigt aber sehr
deutlich was Sie hier für Menschenbild
haben meine Damen und Herren das ist
schäbig und armselig
dabei sollte jeder wissen dass die
Einhaltung von Bürgern und
Menschenrechten nicht nur eine Frage von
Moral und Anstand ist sondern auch ein
Standortfaktor denn dort wo Menschen
frei leben und denken dürfen bringen Sie
sich in die Wertschöpfung ein und dort
lassen Investoren auch gerne ihr Geld
meine Damen und Herren doch leider
zeigen sie einmal mehr Anstand
Wirtschaft und wirtschaftliche
Fachkenntnis ist echt nicht ihr Thema
nun zu ihrem Antrag liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union als
energiepolitiker und zuständiger
Berichterstatter für das Thema
Windenergie es ist mir natürlich ein
Anliegen dass wir die Energiewende
vorantreiben und die Wertschöpfung
Deutschland halten und weiter ausbauen
es sind
344.000 Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland die
es in den erneuerbaren Energien gibt das
sind 40.000 mehr als in der chemischen
Industrie mal so eben das zeigt das
Potenzial was dahinter steckt was hat
das alles mit sicherer Versorgung zu tun
ziemlich viel denn zum Beispiel für die
Produktion von Windenergieanlagen werden
bis 2040 weltweit etwa 22 Millionen
Tonnen verschiedene Rohstoffe benötigt
Stahl Zink Kupfer das Ganze aus der
ganzen Welt was Chile Südafrika aus sehr
sehr viel insofern Wahnsinn sie ja in
ihrem Antrag ziemlich wichtige Anliegen
nur aus der falschen Perspektive heraus
rohstoffpartnerschaften und eine
Diversifizierung der Rohstoffquellen
sind wichtig das ist gekauft alles gut
aber etwas verwundert bin ich da schon
denn viele Punkte die sie bereits schon
in der sind bereits schon Teil der
Rohstoffstrategie der letzten
Bundesregierung und da waren sie glaube
ich schon dabei und wir haben von Frau
Dr Brandner ja gehört dass das hier
weiter angepasst wird und weiter
forciert wird also sie werden hier
kalten Kaffee auf und wie immer und wie
das der Kanzler schon angedeutet hat
wenn sie in Korn finden sind wir dabei
schon das Mehl zu malen und den Kuchen
zu backen also von so her brauchen wir
das gar nicht gut anzugucken das passt
soweit schon aber was ist mit den
Umwelt- und klimaschutzaspekten auch
diese spielen bei der Frage der
Rohstoffgewinnung und des
rohstoffimports eine immer größere Rolle
dazu mal ein Beispiel der Methanausstoß
der muss deutlich reduziert werden denn
Methan fällt zum Beispiel bei der
Gewinnung und Veredelung von fossilen
Brennstoffen an beim Transport in EU
oder auch nach Deutschland auf 20 Jahre
betrachtet ist das Zeug 83 mal
klimaschädlicher als CO2 es ist das ja
gut dass wir die Methan Strategie
gemeinsam mit der Wirtschaft weiter
forcieren aber in ihrem Antrag dazu
findet sich kein Wort was ist mit den
sozialen Aspekten Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Schaffung von Wertschöpfung Jobs
umweltklimaschutz Einhaltung von Bürgern
Menschenrechten das alles muss
zusammengedacht werden und dazu in dem
Antrag kein Wort
lassen sie sich noch ein bisschen was
sagen zum Thema rohstoffabhängigkeiten
und vor allem Diversifizierung man darf
ja ruhig nochmal daran erinnern dass die
Ampelkoalition in einem Jahr die
rohstoffabhängigkeiten jetzt abbauen
muss die die CDU geführt den
Bundesregierung 16 Jahre lang aufgebaut
haben meine Damen und Herren
und man darf auch noch mal daran
erinnern dass ausgerechnet diejenigen
die jetzt nach mehr Unabhängigkeit
brüllen 16 Jahre jede einzelne
Windenergieanlage in Deutschland
bekämpft und beklagt haben liebe
Kolleginnen von Kollegen von der Union
das geht eben nicht mehr heimische
Rohstoffe nutzen wollen aber
gleichzeitig die Nutzung des wichtigsten
Rohstoffs über Jahre und Jahrzehnte
bekämpfen nämlich Sonne und Wind und die
gibt es auch noch umsonst stattdessen
versuchen sie im Antrag ziemlich billig
hinter durch die Hintertür in dem Weg
aufzumachen für unkonventionelles
Tracking für alle die nicht genau wissen
was das ist das ist ein chemie-cocktail
in der in den Boden rein verpresst wird
um den Klimakiller Nummer eins nämlich
Methan also Erdgas aus dem Boden zu
holen und das wollen sie hier in
Deutschland zulassen wir brauchen Erdgas
noch noch aber wissen Sie was besser ist
für die Versorgungssicherheit und für
das Klima als zwei frackingbohrung eine
frackingbohrung in den USA die schon
ausgebeutet wird und die wir nutzen um
von diesem Zeug endlich loszukommen und
endlich eine klimaneutrale erneuerbare
Welt zu schaffen meine Damen und Herren
weil die Zeit ist um letzter Satz wir
stellen uns grundlegend die Frage wie
wollen wir weitermachen wollen wir
weiter Kohlenstoff aus dem Boden holen
der 300 Millionen Jahre eingelagert
wurde den verbrennen und freisetzen wie
die Union oder wollen wir endlich in
einer neue saubere zukünftige Welt gehen
wie wir es tun als Ampel vielen Dank
auch Bengt muss hier ermahnt werden um
zum Ende seiner Rede zu kommen weil die
Zeit abgelaufen ist und was eine Kritik
am können wir unkonventionellen Fracking
angeht muss er gar nicht mal so sehr in
die Unionsfraktion gucken sondern kann
auch in die Koalition gucken denn diesen
Vorschlag hat genau gestern auch der
Bundesfinanzminister wieder aufgegriffen
weil Zitat man ja jeder Energie im
Moment brauche egal wo man sie nur
herholen kann Katrin Henneberger ist die
vorletzte Rednerin in dieser Debatte und
sie gehörte Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen an
universitäts- und Klimakrise sowie die
Ursache der globalen Ungerechtigkeit
immer noch nicht verstanden oder noch
tragischer ihr wollt sie nicht verstehen
weil das würde bedeuten ihr müsstet eure
grundsätzliche Politik in Frage stellen
denn Rohstoffe sind endlich
Ökosysteme nicht grenzenlos belastbar
und die Kipppunkte unserer globalen
Klimasysteme drohen wir derzeit zu
überschreiten als Antwort auf diese
globalen Krisen kompromisslos
kompromisslos national und kurzsichtig
Handeln zu wollen ohne Rücksicht auf die
sozialen und ökologischen Folgen der
Förderung von Rohstoffen in anderen
Regionen der Welt dies ist neokolonial
in eurem Antrag macht ihr keinen Punkt
der die Einhaltung von Menschenrechten
indigenrechten oder Sozialstandards
betrifft ich sehe hier auch keine
Forderungen die die Auswirkungen auf die
lokale Umwelt durch Rohstoffabbau
überhaupt anspricht
statt auszubeuten als gäbe ist kein
morgen auf unserer Erde sollte es besser
das Ziel sein unseren Rohstoffbedarf in
absoluten Zahlen zu senken und achtsam
mit unserer Lebensgrundlage umzugehen
eine neue Rohstoffstrategie sollte die
Grundlage haben eine gerechte Wirtschaft
aufzubauen die nicht beruht auf
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Ausbeutung
von ArbeiterInnen und der Zerstörung
unserer Lebensgrundlage in der Wohlstand
gerecht verteilt wird ein gutes Leben
für alle Menschen statt ein reiches mit
Privatflugzeug nur für ein paar wenige
stattdessen möchte ich die möchte die
Union lieber exzessiv Fracking Öl und
Gas Förderungen betreiben ich war im
Sommer in einer Region Amazoniens wo
Erdöl gefördert wird vergisst Vergiftung
von wasserböden landname der Territorien
indigener Bevölkerung Ursache und
Verstärkung von gewaltsamen Konflikten
das sind die Auswirkungen ich habe eine
Frau besucht die aufgrund ihres langen
Engagements für Umweltschutz und gegen
die Erdölfirmen massiv bedroht wird so
sehr dass die Polizeischutz braucht auch
das sind die Auswirkungen einer
rücksichtslosen Rohstoffpolitik die sich
auch in ihrem Antrag wiederfinden da
wünsche ich mir doch etwas mehr Mut neue
Wege zu gehen
wenn wir
wenn wir nach dem Pariser Klimaabkommen
gehen dann darf es kein weiter so geben
denn neuen Erschließung von Erdöl und
Gasfelder stattdessen müssen wir sehr
dringlich unabhängig uns unabhängig
machen von den fossilen und die
erneuerbare Energiewende global ausbauen
in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich mich
auch bedanken bei den Ministerien die
sich sehr engagieren für
klimapartnerschaften und diese weiter
ausbauen
deswegen möchte ich noch mal betonen mit
Fracking fangen wir gar nicht erst an
wir werden nicht die Verunreinigung von
Grund- und Trinkwasser gefährden was Sie
wirklich brauchen ist eine rohstoffwende
eine Kreislaufwirtschaft aufzubauen und
sozial wie ökologische Standards bei
Lieferketten umzusetzen vielen Dank
das ist eigentlich heute los
Esra Limbacher ist der nächste Redner
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es stimmt
unsere Versorgungssicherheit mit Energie
und Rohstoffen ist aufgrund des
russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine der lieferkettenprobleme
weltweit und der weiterhin auftretenden
Auswirkungen der Pandemie mehr und mehr
gefährdet das trifft beispielsweise die
energieintensive Industrie sowie auch
viele mittelständische Unternehmen in
unserem Land besonders hart es wurde
heute schon viel gesagt ich will die
Möglichkeit nutzen heute auf einen
Treffen von vor zwei Tagen hinzuweisen
und zu berichten dass sich mit der
chemischen Industrie in unserem Land
nämlich dem VCI dem Dachverband der
Industrie hatte sind auch viele
mittelständische Unternehmen die in
diesem Bereich tätig sind die haben mir
berichtet von den großen Sorgen und auch
den Nöten der momentan die momentan in
dieser Branche vorherrscht sie sind
doppelt betroffen weil sie zum einem
Erdgas als Energieträger als wichtigen
Energieträger haben und zum anderen auch
gleichzeitig aus wichtigen Rohstoff für
viele
basis-chemikalien benötigen chemische
Erzeugnisse sind für 90 Prozent aller
produktionserzeugnisse in unserem
Unternehmen in Deutschland notwendig und
ohne diese Chemieindustrie das kann man
sagen steht die ganze Wirtschaft in
unserem Land still liebe Kolleginnen
warum sage ich das warum sage ich das
weil wenn wir über Rohstoffe reden
glaube ich ist es unglaublich wichtig
den Grund überhaupt zu erfahren warum
wir die Rohstoffe hier in unserem Land
brauchen wir brauchen ihn vor allen
Dingen momentan um unsere Wirtschaft
auch am Leben zu halten um unsere
Industrie am Leben zu halten deswegen
will ich die Möglichkeit hier nutzen um
ein klares Bekenntnis zum
Industriestandort Deutschland zu
auszusprechen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich glaube genau in dieser Zeit
ist es besonders wichtig zu sagen wir
stehen zu unserer Industrie wir machen
alles damit sie weiterleben kann wir
lassen Sie nicht im Stich und deswegen
war es auch besonders wichtig heute zum
Tagesordnungspunkt zuzustimmen der
vorhin zur Abstimmung stand dass wir
eben auch die Entlastung die
gaspreisbremse auf den Weg bringen
können da haben sie sich nicht nur
enthalten sondern auch dagegen geredet
ich finde das spricht Bände welche
Partei und welche Koalition und welche
Bündnisse hier in diesem Parlament
überhaupt noch hinter unter unserer
Industrie und unserer Wirt Aufstehen Sie
sicherlich nicht
deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Ampelkoalition hat sich in ihren
Koalitionsvertrag ambitionierte Ziele
gesetzt um eine nachhaltige
Rohstoffversorgung sicherzustellen sowie
die heimischen Rohstoffabbau zu
erleichtern und ökologisch auszurichten
das hat seine Richtigkeit und
Notwendigkeit zum Zeitpunkt der
Verhandlung gehabt und ist heute immer
noch aktuell und auf vor dem Hintergrund
des Gesagten umso wichtiger will aber
vom Kollegen Roloff die Wortwahl
aufgreifen nämlich hat von Siedler von
Catan gesprochen bei diesem Brettspiel
gibt es auch eine entwicklungskarte und
ich finde die sollten wir jetzt ziehen
es gibt und das wird immer notwendiger
auch immer mehr neue Materialien Werk
und Rohstoffe die wir benötigen hier
müssen wir viel viel mehr in
Innovationen und in die Entwicklung in
neuer Patente investieren da ist der
Staat gefördert und ebenso lassen Sie
mich das noch erwähnen müssen wir genau
auf das Potenzial heimischer
Wasserstoffe schauen wir sehen dass die
Vorkommen die im Oberrheingraben
zwischen Basel und Frankfurt entdeckt
worden sind 20 Prozent unseres Bedarfs
nämlich was Lithium betrifft decken
können und Glaube liebe Kolleginnen da
müssen wir noch mal genauer hinschauen
wir sind in einer schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen Lage in unserem Land
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass unsere
heimische Wirtschaft insbesondere
natürlich die Industrie und den
mittelständischen Betriebe bestehen
können dafür tun wir alles mögliche in
dieser Koalition wir handeln um genau
das zu erreichen vielen Dank
[Applaus]